Okay guys, let's dive into April's testing. So I'm trying to kick straight off.
I don't want to
be spending two hours of your time again like last time. So just want to get
straight to the point.
Now, same as always at this point, honestly, we have to set up our indicator. I
'm going to have to
re-say all honor. This is something that trades that I really need to fix.
Because every time you want to enter a new testing session,
like I record for two hours, I want to go take a little snack. Okay, inputs,
UTC.
So, let's go.
11 to 2. Got it. Ladies and dents, I just want to say I apologize in advance if
you hear any
background noises. Currently, I know they do construction. That could be really
annoying.
So apologies if that does affect you anyway. Should maybe be able to get it
edited out, but
yeah. Okay, we're going to dive straight in. I'm not going to waste any time.
We have ISM,
nothing for London session. So where are we from, a structural perspective?
Structurally,
you see we had a shift of these lows. Then we break the lows again, we shift
bullish,
we pull back, we shift bullish. So right now we bullish. Swing low is here.
Swing high is here. Monday, first of April. We've already manipulated Asian
lows.
Do we have a change of character?
No, the entire range is the entire M15 range is the M1 structure as well.
So we are bullish. So we could look at internal. Let's kind of see how London
session plays out.
Okay.
I don't know if we took any other trades applying this principle.
That also doesn't give us the three kind of work anyway. So let's keep moving.
Wait, why is this 1 a.m.? Never mind.
Okay, that would be the confirmation. So that would actually allow us to go
along.
Again, we're trading internal. So I'm going to make a note of this just so we
can kind of,
you know, be clear that we're trading internal. 1 to 5 is pretty much the swing
highs up here.
And straight stops. So I need to make a note of this in the journal.
That is technically M15 pro trend. Like this is all we are following the
playbook.
But from a setup perspective, what I'm going to do is I'm going to add the fact
that it's a
discretion and I'll add the rest of the notes. So it's a 3 30 execution.
News premium discount structure flow.
All right, I'm going to add it as a discretion.
And then we're going to add a note and say the reality is, is that on this
specific setup,
the M1.
Just want to make sure that that's kind of known so that we can collect that
data when we go,
because again, we would just want to kind of compartmentalize all the data, but
I don't want
to get stuck offline. Let's keep playing price.
Okay, there's New York where it equal lows. The reality is it's very likely
that we're going to
trade lower.
And that's the trade lower. So we're bearish now. Cool.
Now we're trading London.
Okay, I would 100% apply discretion here, because in theory,
swing low, swing high, and then low low. I would never consider that as a swing
high ever,
so it just doesn't even exist. That's not a change of character. That on the
other hand, so
it's tradable, but that's going to actually have the confirmation.
There's no price link in here that has three candles. So it's, yeah, non-
existent.
And there's session done. New York session breaks up of highs. That is
technically a change
of character, so we could trade from either a sweep of London, or we could
trade the continuation
created in the London session. And we can trade New York, but I'm getting into
London.
It's our sweep.
So we sweep the high. Okay. Do we have any, what day is it? A third of April.
Do we actually have
any news for this specific day?
Apologies as well. I didn't actually check the news yesterday.
For today, third of April, we do have news. We have ISM, we have power speech,
and then we have
inflation rate at five. So that is, that's a sweep of the highs. So we are
still bullish,
so we're good to look for longs. Have a sweep of you in here.
Is that a shift?
It is.
Is it kind of adequate structure?
It will be. Yeah.
M5. So for this, time is it? Three, four, eight.
That would be myself. What target?
I mean, that's a two R. We pretty much have to get
the expansion to these highs. I'm not really against. If we're looking here on
the M15,
yeah. Kind of would be one to five fixed take profit.
We get tagged at exactly five AM. So we also get tagged in the inflation data.
It frankly isn't a huge deal. Again, like, this is the fourth data release that
we've had,
a third data release that we've had for inflation rate for Euro, and it's
barely moved price.
Okay, we can't go to breakeven yet.
We can go to breakeven now though.
This is unmetigated, but again, price is so far over expanded on the buy side,
that price is even going to get to my target, or it's going to take me at bre
akeven.
One time is it right now, seven AM. Again, it doesn't really matter. ISMs are
10.
This is fine. We're playing out on the 15 minute here. But yeah, I mean, for
this specific position,
you can see that we get tagged in at five AM. So we get tagged in on the
inflation rate data release.
Again, which I said is not a huge deal to be totally honest with you.
We have the sell side liquidity across these lows. This entire area is still un
metigated.
This is what I would consider a much higher quality of setup than the sales
that we've taken
previously. The actual age of sweep on London, et cetera, et cetera. And then
yeah, close out.
So playbook, M15 project and sweep a previous point of interest or session
liquidity,
M1 change of character entry here. We've scaled out appropriately. We haven't
traded
on a session with CPI and FERFMC. And we haven't entered the trade before
retail sales or PCE.
Now what we do have here though on the news is actually we get
held through moderate news technically. We still held this position open
through moderate news.
Premium discount, no. Structure flow.
The structure flow is really void to be honest with you. The trend itself is
just change of character.
Execution window was actually five AM, exactly five AM, session London, point
of interest.
Honestly, I would consider this as a strong point of interest because although
it doesn't
break and close above this high, it does trade above that high. So it does
trade above
something significant, meaning that this level has strength within it. So for
me, that is a strong
point of interest. It's not just a broad point of interest either. It's an
actual solid
area of interest. So that's great. And then London sweep Asia.
Again, you can see it's actually a proper London sweep Asia. And then for New
York session,
I mean, we're bullish now. So could look at trading
continuations, no bulwark, and that's why I don't want to be in for. The ISMs,
these
sorts of things that US news specifically is the high impact news.
Your own news rarely really shakes at the market to be totally honest with you.
Cool.
Let's go to London Sesh, let's see where we're at. So we're obviously bullish.
Is there any significant pullback in here? That's a three kind of pullback. So
that's
being our swing law. For me, it doesn't matter if there's no significant pull
back in here,
but it doesn't matter for me if there is one in Asia. Like if that pullback
exists in Asia,
it's sometimes really just not going to trade. Game, nothing here. That
constitutes only the
two kind of pullback. And then if we fast forward to New York session, let's
see real quick,
make sure that I'm checking news all the time. No news. Nope, nothing. So New
York, again,
nothing. That's not tradable for me. It's a pullback as well. And then nothing.
So London
session, okay, we're bearish now. So we have a change of character. It's the
whole side that
comes change your character. So this here is a breaker structure, but again,
for me personally,
like I don't use Asia session high as a structure point because I'm expecting
it to get rated.
So my structure point remains up here, plain and simple. So it doesn't matter
for me. See,
that's sweet there. That's not a change of character for me. Now price may
continue to
end higher. But for me, just principally, it's not changing character for 59.
That's not going
to be a sell for me. Nope, already passed the window. New York session. You can
see price had
a really nice retracement back into this price level. This could be another
thing as well. Like
maybe, maybe you go out of your way to go and do this test and then kind of see
things like this,
for example, like executing, you know, instead of cutting your window at five,
what happens if
you cut your window at seven? Do you get more trades, less trades, better
trades, worse trades?
Like it's all about testing. And this is the big purpose. The big purpose here,
guys,
is not just to give you a trading strategy. It's to give you the tools and the
skill set and the
mind to be able to think and move like a trader. Because what we're doing right
now, this is real
trading, right? Anyone can follow a trading strategy and make money. But the
reality is,
if you want to be a long-term winner in this game, you need to learn how to
play the game really.
So there's the London sweep, there's the Asia, New York sweep on London, which
is nice.
Didn't check news today. And that's NFP, obviously. Of course. Okay, so no
trading NFP days anyway,
to settle down for you or in an ideal world. Avoid it. Now, you can see we have
that continuation,
lower, but I'm better off just going to the next day's session. Okay, so we're
in this area of price.
Asia highs here. Do we have any news that is the real question?
We have balance of trade at two. So right now, balance of trade is about to
come out. And you'll
see like that, that two am kind of right there. That's a red fold news event
for Euro. And it did
nothing. So I just understand that for news events during Europe, it's really
minor. Nothing for London,
we're probably going to sweep these highs. New exceptions already started.
Nothing for me,
again, it's void. I don't care about it for me. If I try to take a short
position and Asia high
hasn't been taken significantly lowers the the favor I have of that setup. It
doesn't matter.
So that would be a change of character. So now we are bullish. I don't like
this liquidity down
here at these lows and the swing lows down here. So eyes on that. But if Asia
creates in here and
then sweep and then go, you know, you know how it goes. Okay, looks like we've
got continuations.
Let's have a little look. Intraday low. Cool. So we can sweep that low like
that.
And if we can get a reversal like that, then we may indeed.
Can be a little bit tricky to reprice action in this kind of early Asia.
I know it can be tricky, but just follow the same principles.
So let me just clarify real quick.
So yeah, Monday of April. The M1 acts the same as almost the M15. Do you have
any news today?
This is Monday, right? We do. Oh, well, we just went through it. It was balance
of trade.
Okay. So we don't have any more news, neither of you accessionizer.
Okay. Yeah, again, just attention to details. You can see that this is
obviously the swing high.
So this high gets broken here. New high, pullback, higher high, lower low, pull
back, continuation of
lower low, price changes character here back to bullish. And from there, there
's no,
there's no three kind of pullback in any of this price action.
So the swing low is unfortunately here, which means London shifts bearish here,
but we're looking
for longs. And for price to shift back to long, we'd have to see this high go.
So either London is to come back down and then shift or we can't trade it.
Now it's broken down. There's a pullback, another low and then shift and we can
, but it's going to be too late.
Yeah, that's okay. And then New York continues again, it's what I was looking
for. I was
looking for that continuation, that shift, but it doesn't happen until here.
There's no trade.
In this scenario, swing low is now here. So we can trade from, you know, pretty
much
kind of this area, really, as our point of interest.
There's nothing for choosing ninth. We don't have anything. We just really
check it, right?
Yeah, ninth, nothing. 10th is what we have ever seen, but tomorrow's news day
is just nuts.
There's only two candles, so we just narrowly missed. There's no setup in there
for me.
I don't see that really as a point of interest. It's debatable, obviously, but
even if it was,
there's no, there's no entry model and there's probably not going to be a trade
. Nope.
So now we go to London. Now on this day, we have to be very careful. We have
CPI, FOMC that's going
to come later. Again, when FOMC minutes is falling on CPI, we're going to get
the inflation rates
and then we're going to get kind of a discussion on that. So I would be very
kind of surprised
if there wasn't kind of low volume for this day specifically London. Yeah, but
where are we from?
A structural perspective.
It's just bearish. We continue bearish. We shift bullish. We continue bullish.
We continue bullish.
So it's still technically bullish, but we've already liquidated our swing low,
which is an issue. This low felt a great new high and we look at it again. For
me, that's just
it's a difficult one. It doesn't even give us a confirmation in reality. Again,
sometimes you
may seem to take a sweep in real life, but this isn't real life. But it's a
difficult one,
especially on a day like this. Like you see in price, you see in price,
manipulate this low once,
come back up, manipulate it twice again, create equal lows at this low. I just
I don't like that
low at all. 7.45 again, obviously just steering straight up clear of New York
because that's crazy. That's like crazy crazy. But that does change things up a
lot.
And again, in hindsight, we now understand that was probably just to grab up
liquidity
before the real move. Also internal rate of liquidity into this old move. So
this buy in here,
this buy in here is more than likely an inducement. So liquidity used to push
price higher to induce
all of the people so that they can take the sell side of the market because
they understand
what's really about to happen most likely. So we're obviously bearish,
extremely bearish.
We've also taken out kind of an extreme high time frame level as well, puts us
in a bit of a difficult
kind of price action. Yeah, this is kind of where things get difficult because
we can take shorts,
but we're so far down in the price like this is obviously considered no man's
land. So it's the
11th, obviously off the back of Dun Dun Dun Dun, off the back of CPI we have
ECB. So this is
something where you want, you may want to pay attention as well. When you have
a European news
event that's released in New York session, there's a decent chance of it being
impactful.
We have PPI in New York at 830 and then at 815 we have interest rates and
deposit
deposit facility rates and then we also have ECB price conference 30 minutes
after to
discuss those numbers. So obviously extremely bearish. The thing is as well is
when you see
such an aggressive selloff in New York such a big selloff as well, not just a
small one,
the following day in the London session, you may see some of the London traders
or funds also
trying to kind of capitalize and get involved in that move as well. Maybe that
's something that we
may play on, but again not a huge round of this price action. That's also swing
high. So kind of
that's a break. So this becomes a structural high.
I'm not trading from any recession. Respect. That's a sweep. That's nicer.
Does it give us an entry signal? Lower prices, higher prices, higher prices.
Not really. That's just really messy price action where the M15
is really in somewhat aligned with the M1. It's also five o'clock. Yeah, good.
Because that
price action is not clean. And the New York session is not something we want to
trade on this specific day.
As you can see, sweep out of the sell side and then push into buy side where it
shifts as bullish.
And then we also go back to bearish. That's just understanding of
really understanding prime liquidity. I like that because I much prefer this as
a swing high
after the sweep of that as well. So that's cool. Let's go to London, see if the
high holds does.
Let's go and see if we have anything one day. It's going to be the 12th, Friday
the 12th.
We have Michigan consumer sentiment at 10. Okay.
So we're good to trade through London as well. I would need to see a sweep of
those age of
highs and we're not going to get them. Which means technically speaking, swing
high becomes
here, which not a huge fan of, but we'll play it. Probably not going to get a
position today.
Highly unlikely at this point. Oh, that's not why I was intended to do it. Okay
. Obviously,
there was myself. No pullbacks in here. So we're still bearish. It's now Monday
the 15th.
And so we're still bearish. This is my broad point of interest. Anything below
this is
No Man's Land. Kind of what I refer to as. And so yeah, pretty much New York
session high.
This is not Monday the 15th of April. What do we have? We have retail sales. So
again,
with retail sales, we want to be very cautious. We can hold it. Not say we can
't hold a position
through retail sales, but we don't want to be entering on retail sales. So
there's a that's a
sweep. So we get a reversal. We could trade. Is that M1 structure bullish? Yeah
, it has to be.
Yeah, it is cool. So we can trade.
This area in here. What's the rest of the award?
Pretty much perfectly. One to five rest reward.
Let me make it increase the chance of getting tagged in. I like holding on this
seven pip stop.
Maybe a little bit superstitious six, nine,
seven, exactly. Five are.
Oh, no, it doesn't.
Five point three.
Maybe then we go.
That's my stop here. So five, eight.
That's six, five.
It's six point five pip stop. Still giving us more handles than we need.
Increase the probability of getting tagged in. One to five straight up.
We'll go sell limits in here. Monday, 15th April, we have, what was it? Retail
sales.
Okay, one of the courses up.
What time are we three a.m. Should we come? That's tagged. It's a reaction.
A time will be four, three, five. Okay. Still no break even really.
Okay, I like that reaction.
Okay, I don't like that. 740, 750, 810,
830. I don't have my stops to break even for retail sales.
It's yeah, most in our direction. Sometimes that's also how the sometimes that
is also how the
grumbles. Also just missed the chance to get involved from New York set up.
Again, I just
want to take this specifically. We ended up actually leaving. If it would have
had our stops
dead on London highs, that would have been a stop literally just by adding that
just to make it
the five hour that played my favorite a lot. But
when New York sweeps London,
M1 is already technically bearish.
No, it's not. It's bullish here.
It's just bearish here.
Bearish continuation here. It's just bullish here. It's just bearish on the
breakdown here.
So that's again holding a trade through moderately impactful news. Sometimes
you might get an
aggressive retail sales like this. Sometimes retail sales may not be as
aggressive. But most
important thing is stop to break even non-negotiable. Even if you're not
technically
qualified for break even, you still need to have your stops at break even.
Because if price
pings off in the other direction, I'm going to get tagged out. And I may even
incur some level
of slippage. It depends on what position size I'm using. It depends on the
depth of market.
But that's important to note. Again, you'll see how we run through that in our
journal.
That's pretty fortunate though. If it hits, you might not even hit. We're going
to type that
break even. So it's not actually really that fortunate. Is it? Oh, wait.
Our stops are at break even right now.
I would still be happy to keep my stops at break even for my London position
but at the same time.
We've just shifted bearish on for the New York session. And we have
M15 that I got in here. Because if price is going to retrace, which it does
before taking the
swing lows, then this is still a quote unquote good quality self.
A five minute time frame.
The buy to sell still kind of a mitigated. Sometimes you'll see me flick
through time frames as well
because I'm trying to find the most likely kind of area of gravitational pull
for price to come back to. And again, the majority of the time, what I'm really
looking
for is I'm looking for the liquidity used to run an area. So the buy side
liquidity
in here that's used to push price higher, that makes an order block. If it's a
15 minute time frame,
it's really this level. And so you can look at refining that but it's the risk
to reward favorable.
Gain 5.7, keep our stops at the same high as the London set up.
Gain on us is a little bit unorthodox.
Because I just replay price, but I need to stop moving so fast as well.
Okay, so that puts a limit on for the New York set up. So these are two
independent
apps. They are different. So this is a limit. Now this. What's this?
Okay, this is my stop. So this stop right now is a break even. The problem is,
is the this is unmetigated. And so I'm adding risk by doing this. I'm
essentially scaling
into a position that has open risk. In the live market, I probably wouldn't do
this
to be totally honest with you. I would just keep one position even open with no
stops on.
Or what I would do is I would put the London session, the London entry at break
even,
especially prices down here as well, the London session at break even, but the
New York
order on the same break even. And so that's counterintuitive. But essentially
the principle
is is that one of the positions would would get left open. So I don't think I
would literally
take London to put it at break even. I just wouldn't open New York's position.
But maybe some of you guys were watching this. Maybe some of you were trading
London,
and some of you are trading New York. So although you could go to break even,
this area of price is unmetigated. This entire area that's just been traded
through
from retail. I'm just over talking this entire thing, and this could end up
just running straight
through the highs and just ruining me. But I'll make a note as well,
because the reality is, is in an ideal world, I don't have one of these
positions open.
In the reality right now is I wouldn't have two of these levels. So it doesn't
make sense.
I wouldn't double down on my risk in the same exact level, unless I'd been able
to pull risk
off the table in one position. So for me, I would just have one position open,
just to be clear.
That's not a bad reaction. My management would be above this high.
That's the type of trade that I could scale in on. For example, now, if the
sale made sense,
and that was the trade, so it wasn't the exact same area. This is basically the
exact same trade.
But if price had come back in, tag me, and then trade it out from here, I could
put my trade on
here again. If price had come back in and then traded away from that level, and
I could put a
new trade on here, where my stop loss on that trade here, then what I could do
is I could take
the stop loss of this trade, put the stop loss of this trade at the same stop
loss as that trade.
And therefore, if price tag is like this, and it moves in our favor, then I
essentially have,
you know, double the reward with like half of the risk, because if I put one
full lot of risk on
here, and I move the stop loss from here to here, that might net me, you know,
probably 0.5 R.
And so by doing so, technically, if price runs this stop loss, I lose 0.5 R.
Because I gained 0.5 R here, and I lose one R here, which leaves me negative 0.
5 R.
But if it tags me in, and moves to my profit, then I have two positions open
for five R,
and it's Hennar. And so that's how I can gain the scaling. But when the scaling
is the exact
same trade in the same stop loss area, then now you're basically just putting
double risk on the
same setup. So there's a difference. Because the key is, is when you can move
your stop loss
to a level that now shouldn't get traded through, and enter from that same
level, right,
and price kind of runs the lows, we do. Okay, so to be clear, if I was to trade
this in life,
I would have one of these positions open because I wouldn't just double down on
my risk in the
same position, it doesn't make sense. But I understand number one, for the
system perspective,
we need the actual data of the system. And number two, maybe one of you guys
trades,
only London session one, maybe one of you guys trades only New York session. So
be kind of cognizant
of that. Okay. These are both two different ones. This is the London short.
Everything is
aligned. I'm over playing in the game halfway through four or four minutes.
Maybe a little bit.
The first setup is London sweep. Asia. Point of interest. No man's land.
Session London obviously. Trend is change of character, right?
No. Reversal confirmed. Structure flow.
Internal bullish. Internal counter trend on that one premium discount now. News
. Okay.
For this one, we held through moderate news, right?
Yes. We held through moderate news, whilst being at break even during the news
event,
then we move our break even after the news event to allow price to kind of
remake it.
The execution window is three to four AM. Okay, that was borderline confusing,
but
we got it. This is the New York session. Everything is the same. We're bearish.
We sweep London high.
This is a New York, New York sweep London. Point of interest. Empty leg session
. New York trend
is confirm reversal. Structure flow. On this one, we actually have kind of
internal bearish. So
price puts in these highs. Pull back. Highs. Pull back. Highs, technically, and
then shift.
So this is actually pro trend. So this is going to be the kind of the fewer
trades will be
internal pro trend, but I'm really interested to see whether they become an A+
set up because
logically they should. No. News. Okay, entered after news. Execution window. 9
AM. 9 at 5. So
9 to 10. Okay. London. Okay, next day. Still bearish. Again, this is honestly
where I would
be applying discretion again. You see, we break structure right here. And the
swing high is
basically Asia. Again, for me, swing high at Asia. Like I'm expecting this area
to get run. Where's
my breathing room? I don't have breathing room. So logically, you can even just
see objectively.
Price bottoms out on the swing. We have a pullback. We put in the swing and put
in a lot of prices.
And so for me, I'm still looking at this. This, for me, is -- I wouldn't even
consider it discretion,
but it's the same principle over and over and over again. But I'll label it as
discretion so
that at the end, we can understand what should that be a principle or not. All
right, that's what
you guys can do is we have building permits, not a problem, and then pal speech
. I want to be out
for that. So what you can do is, as a setup, you can kind of add discretion as
a tag and then take
trades that, for example, like this one, right? I don't know if this is going
to play out,
but let's say hypothetically, price was to come up into here and give a shift
like this,
because that's what I would actually be expecting to happen. Then I would trade
that, but this would
be a change of character. Now, sometimes you might get this wrong. This may
change character,
and then price continues. That's why it's important. Like tag it as a quote-un
quote
discretion, so that at the end of all of your data collection, you can go back
and you can look
at that specific filter, and then you can understand, did it make sense to
trade like that? And so,
when you add discretion and then you go and look through the trades, it just
starts seeing a pattern.
Either it's working for you or it's not, right? But quite simple. And if it's
working for you,
then keep doing it. If it doesn't work for you, then either change it or get
rid of it. It's
so simple. Again, that becomes a continuation, which means that now is my swing
high, which
honestly, I really don't like. I really don't like the fact that Asia High hasn
't been taken,
16th of April, build impairments. I don't like the fact that Asia's session
hasn't been taken.
That's a sweep of the high. I'm not interested in trading that. Not interested
in trading any of that.
That's what I'm expecting. So now, do I consider, are we bullish? Do we change
character or are we
bearish? It's 5 a.m. We have building permits at exactly 8.30. So technically,
we change character.
Let's just see how price plays out. Cool. So New York opens.
I like the fact that price continues, at least it gives some level of
conviction. So in theory,
our swing low is down here. Right. That's our swing low. Price falls bare.
Probably not from there.
Yeah. This already doesn't matter. London session. Okay. Again, I don't like
this price action at all.
The fact that price liquidates is low. Again, I was already expecting the
reality is probably
the price will trade lower. So we liquidate this low. Do you want to look for
longs? No, thank you.
I would much rather, in a daily with price action like this, I would much
rather sit out of London.
Right. I would literally much rather see out of London. The price comes back
down.
Respect the level. Continue trading higher. Is there an entry in here?
No. Always bear when there's not an entry on a trading day that you've decided
to see out of.
This is where everything becomes sticky because now that should be running
through that high.
Okay. London session. Okay. Price moves higher. When this high gets broken,
I'm 100% now have the conviction that it is. So that becomes a change of
character.
This is a pullback. That becomes a breaker structure. And yeah. So we're
bullish from,
we're bullish from technically this low here, to be honest, but we'll call it
at this low.
So some tire price ligers is bullish.
I need to see sweep of the sell side. Nope. New York sweep of sell side. Can we
get a lower
timeframe shift? Nope. London session. Still bullish. Again, the reality is, is
that I would
need to see this Asia low be taken. Price might respect this level. It doesn't
really like
affect me because I'm still not going to trade it. I'm still not going to trade
that.
New York still not going to trade that. I would rather see that happen than try
and trade it because I understand the probability. We're still bullish. So I'm
looking for longs.
I've just skipped two days without even checking the news because I knew I wasn
't going to trade
it. I wasn't going to get to trade anyway. Whereas on a day like this, there's
actually
a much higher probability that I end up getting to trade. So 22nd on a Monday.
Let's see what we've got.
Nothing I don't think. No. No. 22nd on Monday.
Nothing. So I want to see a sweep of those Asia lows like that. Can we get an M
1 shift?
No pullback in here. Obviously, that's a pullback. Knitted the high get taken
out. Like that.
Five. I'm not tagged in. Again, that may be something that you want to test for
yourself.
If you've got a position set up, allowing it to run 30 minutes over or
something like that,
that's totally on you. But for the purpose of just testing the system, they're
also the rules.
Beautiful equal lows here. I expect in New York sell off and then potentially
look for a position.
There's the New York sell off. That should be an entry, I would assume. Yeah.
Where are we coming from? We're coming from a weak point of interest. No, right
? Yes.
We're bullish, internally she's bearish. You could argue that it's a strong
point of interest.
In the sense that it's a price like the break structure. My entry point.
And 15 and five.
Pretty much just looking for this level. Do we have news today? I think we said
it was clear.
Four, four, three, we'll make it five. Again, even with that, sometimes you
might see me
stretch my stuff a little bit. If I have a breathing room, meaning logically,
if prices
don't have to overextend or run to an area that doesn't make sense here, five r
, I'll give
us a little bit of breathing. So that's the five r. But the reality is, is I
want price to trade.
All the way up here. So that's my overall trade.
But I want to take profits. If we get into the trade first and foremost, what
time are we on?
Are you tired? Oh, I want to be careful that I said I kind of feel good. Okay.
Tagged and stopped. Cool.
Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah.
And this is really kind of like London, New York, sweet London.
Point of interest is a strong one. Obsession is New York. Trend is.
I'll say that's a pro trend. Yeah, it's in period. No, no news. Execution
window.
Nine to ten.
Oh, maybe I'll just get another entry. Probably not though.
No. Cool. That's a London game. Sometimes I should have a couple of crumbles.
Really nice sweep of the Asia for that London session law. I respect this Asia
session.
We're still bullish. So we're still looking for long because Tuesday the 23rd
of April.
What do we have here? I'm just going to get past it. We have a h-cob.
Can be, what time is it? It is three, three, three. Can be impactful. It's kind
of something
that we consider as semi impactful. Obviously, we've shifted Asia lows. Let's
see what happens
when London opens. Well, aggressive sell off. There's no shift in there. Not a
chance. That's
a h-cob, legitimacy. Right, 315. So that's coming 15 minutes before. So someone
knew something
because price died moving before that day was released. Okay, and h-cob is
something that you
do want to pay attention to. At this point, we've taken this one high. But, I
mean, we're still
technically bullish. So, yeah. This would be my kind of, quote unquote, broad
point of interest here.
Let's see, New York. I have a broad point of interest, which is this region
here. So this entire
kind of sell to buy is the broad point of interest. And then for kind of like a
quote unquote strong point of interest, maybe this inverted anything kind of in
this area and below.
Really? This inverted hourly figure. That's a such a solid area of interest.
I like the look of this. Yeah, but really what's important is just the actual
lower time frame
shifts. Again, I say this all the time. It doesn't matter so much about the
point of interest.
It matters more about what happens there. So if we play forward 6, 37, we hit
that level
and we hit it with an aggressive reaction actually straight off the bat. Do we
have a shift in here?
No. Price needs to shift above this high. We can see price shift above that
high.
Whoa. Okay. So now we need to choose a point of interest to drive from.
So let's recap real quick. So we're bullish from height to low. I had to pull
back. We've shifted
internally bullish. This is arguably like an A+ setup. And again, I throw this
term around because
it's really difficult, but it's just the stack of consequences. With doing this
test, I'm trying to
kind of redefine A+ setups by understanding kind of data. But the reality is is
tracking
something like all of these different consequences that kind of a once is
difficult.
Why? We have bullish structure, obviously, but we have a large range and we've
realigned
from both externally to entirely realigns and then again straight away from
here.
And now we're trading from the direct leg, the aggressively sweeps Asia and
aggressively sweeps
higher with a very, very, very nice one-hour price like into an invite for you
and immediately
begins to have an aggressive reaction. That's the type of position that you
want to get into.
And even if like, if we look at this, this one hour with a block here,
what is it like on the one minute, for example? A 15 minute even. Right. It
encapsulates the
entirety of the move. How large is that?
There's 10 pips. I don't want it to be 10 pips. You want something in the
ballpark
region of, in this market conditions in 2024, you want it to be ballpark figure
kind of
five to seven pips-ish would be nice. What about if I use to have an inverter
like this?
Have an m15 that I got.
7.9 pips start. 7.7 pips start. Is the rest of the water?
4.4. Okay.
I would like to use the full one hour to make sure the answer is here.
But the rest of water doesn't make sense.
Could just use the m15 for value up.
And just kind of expand a little bit. Don't need to see price hit this level.
Is that stop? Again, you'll see tight stops when there's no room, but there's
no wiggle room.
You might see me be able to kind of loosen my stuff a little bit if there is
some wiggle room.
So that's like on the absolute point of price. I could bring it up to here, but
then I'm like
just playing with fire really. I'd rather expect price to run a little bit
higher than not trade
for that level. Kind of m15 for value up entry. Basically, just have to see
this one how it's
get taken. And again, what's that? That's like a 7.7 pips start. So sometimes,
like I said,
you know, the playbook says, you know, between one and five minute order block.
And the reality is, is like, that's why I'm playing it off. I'm still playing
it off of the
context of the one to five minute. But the, like, for example, if I just come
in here now and
go to a five minute timeframe and expect price to come all the way back down to
here, when it's
already such a large price range, right, there's sometimes where you can expect
price to come back
down to here, when the price range isn't already so large, like the the risk
reward on that, for
example, wait, let me come to this order. Because it should actually be this
law.
Okay, that's why. That's 5.2.
Apologies for my sometimes. Autistic tendencies. Yeah, I think it helps though.
A little bit of autism actually helps, true. Oh, yeah. So my point is, is like,
if I try and
expect price come all the way back down here, it does increase my rest of the
world ratio, sure.
In some market conditions, I might expect it, sure. But I care about more than
anything else
getting into the trade. Like sometimes price might just come back into the
field. Like,
look at the one hour. Really and truly what I'm expecting to happen is to price
them and get
the one hour. And so already by using the M15, I'm, you know, in some sense,
decreasing the
probability of me getting in. But because it's here, I think price will trade
back into the M15,
like, but the reality is, is like, I want to look at the order flow. I don't
care, but I'm not
just pattern recognition. I want to look at the order flow. So what we see in
the order flow is
highlighted. No, just give me the brush. I said I would not waffle. We're on an
hour and 10 minutes,
and we're not done. We hit here, we start slowing down, we have another ret
raction,
then price comes back in, and then price really sits in this range for a while.
Right, in this entire range, then we have another sweep. This really is a load
up phase for sure,
and then the expansion begins taking out here. So the real kind of sell to buy
comes in this region.
And by using the M15, there you go, I'm increasing the probability is that I
get into the trade
about trying to over refine my position, because something I used to do so much
consistently,
try to over refine a position that ends up getting you missed entries. Watch
this now
come all the way back to my return entry. But like I said, man, like for me, it
's more important to
get into the position. Look at how aggressive that is in the five minute. You
really think
price coming all the way back down to this specific level. Okay, I don't know
if price
will come back. Price may even literally come back to the one hour order block,
tap it and run.
Like that's already pretty much back to the order block.
Right, because it's all about just previous liquidity. It's all liquidity. It's
all supply
around. Price comes back into the previous cluster and then trades out.
Fortunately,
we may get back into this cluster. No, maybe yes. Now we're in the major
cluster. Even if it comes
to a five minute, right, look at the detail on the five minute, you can only
see it. The real cluster
is we have sell off base, sell off base, and then the real move. This is the
sell to buy on a
higher time frame, which is what you look at when you look at the one hour. And
that's in the M15.
45. Why is there a one minute candle like that? What is this? 20/23rd of April.
There's nothing.
And it's a very weird one minute candle, to be honest.
Trading future is nothing. Why did price actually work twice into?
Price will trade its portfolio into this M15, how you got it.
Trading view shows nothing.
That's too much of an aggressive one minute candle.
To not be from nothing. We didn't even get that in...
What was it? A h-cop. I don't understand.
Is there any news?
I don't see anything. This is a bunch of macro events, but no specific news
event. I don't know
whether a price action like that, you would expect something happened to be
totally honest with you.
Cool. Again, apologies. I know that I take so long to record these.
Like each of these months is like two hours long. It's like 15 months, like 30
hours of back testing.
This is a New York continuation from London, POI. London is bullish, New York
comes back into the
London session. Point of interest, for me strong. Session, New York, trend. We
are
confirm reversal. Wait, yes, we're seeing that same price. Like,
compare reversal, structure, flow. This is what I mean. We're pro-pro. We're
not in premium at discount.
News, apparently not, but it doesn't seem like it to me. Execution window, like
that could have...
I don't know, maybe it might have been thinking it, but that could have been
the opposite direction.
That's not fun. It's not fun, kind of. Execution is 9.30. Also, what news
happens between
usually news is like 8.30 or 10 or 2.
Cool. Well, that's that.
Now we're coming back to London. So we are bullish. Now we're taking out the
swing highs.
But guess what? The new structural lows still down here. So it's still a really
large price leg.
Today we have news. Apparently. One day is it. Now it's the 24th. Now we have
news.
Durable goods. IFO 4. I'm not really bothered about IFO. Cool. I'm looking for
longs.
And there's no compliment. There's no reversal in that. There may be one there.
At this point, I can already read as well by the way. The M15. The M1 price
actually, the M15.
And the M5.
Do we run that high? That's a really interesting. Even redistribution or
recommendation. Probably a
redistribution. Cool. Probably not going to get set up, are we? 4.30. No, that
's not a shift.
And there's a session done. There's a New York.
Again, you need to see a sweep of London low. Sweep of London low like that.
That's AAM.
Durable goods. That's durable goods.
That's after durable goods. Cool. Let's have a look at what we have here.
So we have the sweep.
And the reversal. The reversal comes here.
But if I had to set this on news,
it honestly wouldn't really expect anything from that news.
Sweep reversal. Maybe not. Let's see how price plays out here.
That's tradable. Minds low.
Difficult to get actually an accurate area of interest to trade from.
I see price comes back.
Yeah, I wouldn't be in that. Just now, probably not to be honest.
Why not? No. If I would have went with M15, I would have used that.
Cool. That's why I would have used if I would have taken it.
And again, like I said, you can do your own independent testing.
If you want to collect data and see what's like trading this system at later
hours,
earlier hours, whatever you want, this is just where I'm out with the system.
But that's where I would have traded from. So we bullish, we continue.
Probably not going to get a trade. New York session.
It's a state that's going to be
in GfK. Gb.
We're just not going to trade after that, are we? That's be real. No. London.
Cool. Where does that
pose? How does that put things into perspective? So shift, respect the laws,
create equal laws. I don't like that liquidity.
Friday as well. Let's see what we have in store for us in the news.
PC. So I don't want to be in a trade for that.
Um, is there any thinking in actual?
Nothing for London. I already know which way to deliver pricing to be honest
with you because,
well, I guess we're bullish, but
it's just marketing price action. Let's just, let's see.
Okay. Well, if I was going to trade long anyway, it would have had to be below
Asia session.
So it doesn't really matter. Again, that doesn't really give us clear cut
structure, but we do have
PC in seven minutes.
No. Nope. That's not clear. Yeah. That's not clear.
Cool. Still really not last perception. Okay. That's the liquidation I was
waiting for.
Now, now we have direction.
Swing high, swing low. Pretty simple. We're already above previous days high.
Uh, apologies. What about structure?
So is there a pullback? Nope. Nope.
Yep. That is a three kind of work, right? One candle. Two candles. Three
candles.
Okay. So that constitutes the pullback, which means
that is a Frankfurt sweep and
a London confirmation. So now that we've had the additional shift, so when this
model is pretty
simple, Frankfurt sweeps, it shifts, London has to pull back and continue.
And we can trade based on that. She's really made a quickly check news
before I actually enter the trade. Stop placement.
This becomes a tricky one. Now, we have to find an area to place our stops,
because logically speaking, I want to see a price for trade over down here.
It's a little bit of a different scenario. You see, sometimes where you might
find me say,
I don't really think price won't trade down there. I'm going, I could be
getting ahead of myself.
I don't care if I'm wrong. I just want to give context because it's not about
being right.
But sometimes you might need to say like, I don't expect price to swing for the
fences,
even though it's the M15 swing low. The reason is context, because in this
specific price action,
you can quite closely see we have a real aggressive rate above the highs and
the aggressive sell off.
And now we're in the pullback in here. And so I am expecting that continuation.
In a different type of price scenario, it might be so much less clear. You
might have like some
like this, where price comes down here, and then price starts coming back up.
Right. And then you might be in here, and this might be a swing high. This
might be a swing low,
and it's just really like a much larger price leg, whereas this is just
straight high to low to
pullback to lower, lower expectation. The question is, is where the part entry
in the
other question is, is do we actually have a news event? Because if price is
this low,
I need to run for and understand the order flow here. But the question is, is
do we have news?
It's the 29th of April. We have inflation rate at AAM, east and standard time.
So yeah, we probably want to be cautious of that.
Yeah, I don't really know if I'll hold through that per se. Is there anything
else?
Okay, then we have a crazy day on the side as well.
Is that okay? Okay. So from a management perspective,
how do we want to protect ourselves? We're in a nice area. I like the area of
price.
How do we plan to protect ourselves? This is mitigated.
This is mitigated continuation. The best risk to reward play would be to take
this.
The best risk to reward play would be to take that, but the safer play would be
to cover the
stops at the highest. What does this become? 8.8. It becomes a 5R, nah. I would
rather
play the risk here and at least I can close the position at 5R.
Because I would have surprised to hit 5R instead of run all the way to these
lows.
Again, I'm not saying that can't happen. That very much might happen, but I don
't know.
But I definitely have breathing room, so I can 3.8. Let me stretch out a little
bit.
So that's the overall trade that I'm looking at.
But I want to make sure that I'm taking profits at 5R.
Especially, we have today's, nothing compared to tomorrow's news day is wild.
But we'll see how it plays out. Do we get tagged? Looks like no. Wait, 3.4?
Looks like yes.
Okay. Okay. We can, we can go stop to break even.
Now, the thing is, is if the price is this level, I need to be cognizant
because I need
to close this at 5R. Wait, what do you mean cancel all that?
Okay, close 50%. About 5R. And then, let the rest of this position run down to
these
lows in here. What time is it? 4.45. Let's go to New York session. Okay, we're
back in the
same point of interest. But we could trade it from here from New York
technically.
Okay, that's break even. Okay, so that's going to be an entry. Is it not?
Yes. So, in 40 minutes, we have inflation rate preliminary, so just preliminary
.
Yeah, I don't really expect too much of an impact. Could be wrong, but this
would be
the entry in the trade through moderate news. Probably more inclined to go
fair value gap here. Let's see what the rest of the water stuff looks like.
Again, you can see I can be dynamic in my approach to
my expectation of price. We also have the inverted value gap here as well. What
's the
risk reward on this? If we can take out this lower, we get that would be more
one to five.
I mean, very possible logically. I'm going to have to open the position. If I
want to
take the position, I'm going to have to open it through inflation rates. The
likelihood is
that's not going to get tagged or termed as an inflationary on your preliminary
. The last time
that we had the aggressive price delivery, it wasn't just a preliminary. It
also came with the
or was it not preliminary? Previous year's inflation data. Okay. Let's see how
this plays out.
We've already closed a profit as well. One to five. This is where I really want
to
again, partial. Let's play five minute candle by five minute candle. We may not
even get tagged in.
7.55. That's eight. We're tagged before. So we're tagged 25 minutes before.
Okay. Is the data released? Yeah. So it's nothing. Okay. Take note of that.
Again, sometimes it's what you'll have. Like sometimes it also depends on the
actual data that's
released. So the same news event can have a much larger impact if the data is
kind of much different
obviously. But the thing is, is that was different. So that was inflation rate
gear on your preliminary.
Whatever that means. But the previous inflation data, the one that actually
caused large price moves,
it wasn't that. Try to find it. I would like to take a mental note of that.
Flash. It was inflation rate year on year flash. Yeah. I've got it here as well
.
The the inflation data year on year flash did move price. Okay.
So again, not a big macro guy. I'm not going to say here and pretend that
anything macro because
it's just not something that I actually really intricately pay any attention to
. I know the basics.
So here I would look at managing the position. I could arguably even scale in.
We've already
locked profit in this one. I'll give you a scale in. What time is it? 845. Why
not?
This kind of final cluster. Because if I put my stops above here now,
right, we'll give it a little bit of a breathing room. Well, now this is 0.5.
And so if I can
essentially get myself to risk another 0.5, all right, and still only be a
total risk of one.
So if I'm going to place the order, I'm going to place it at 0.5%. So I'm going
to add an additional
0.5% of risk. If price comes back, because even if it tags out, then I still
only lose one.
R, but we've already returned two and a half for the same day. So it's just
about scaling in when it
makes sense. We're approaching our 5R in our first position. I don't think
price is going to come back
to this level. Hmm. That's my bar. Okay, which one's which? So you here, when I
close 50% of you,
what time is it? 942. Price is not coming back to you. So I'm going to remove
my limit.
And I'm going to bring my stop loss to
break even. I don't see the reason that I'm surprised to return back to this
area at this point. To be honest, there's no way of scaling. Should just expect
some price to run
through these lows. Or not. So outside of session. So break even.
Interesting. That price doesn't take those lows. I need to journal them. Let me
just
say very well. Interesting. So I mean, arguably, if I would have protected this
high, I would have
been still in the position, but still sort of 5R here instead of. Okay, the
first short
is the London session. So again, don't need. I don't know. I follow my flavor.
My tags that set up is it is a Frankfurt sweep continuation. So Frankfurt
sweeps Asia,
gives a change of character, and then London opens with a continuation.
POI, that's a strong point of interest for sure.
Session London trend, trend character, structure flow,
aesthetically count trend, premium discount, yes, news.
What was the situation for this news?
There wasn't any for the London session. And then the execution window.
That was three to four. Cool. That's you, Don. How long are we recording for?
And I'm sorry. We're almost done now. So I mean, it's faster than the last time
.
Trade notes. See if we can get down to the hour next time. Playbooks.
I know I follow this. I'll wait there. Don't answer before it ourselves.
So this is actually a, this is a London point of interest continuation.
So this is a New York continuation from London. We have London session opens.
We have the aggressive move. London comes back into it, trace the wave map.
Point of interest is technically week, session, New York trend,
change character, structure flow, and the structure flow is internally bearish.
It's nice. It's not a pro trend, because we have entirely comes up here,
and then it shifts bearish at this break, and then continuation.
So it's nice. Yes. News held through modern news. Did we, did we hold that?
Yeah, we did. Okay, we had it from modern news.
It was, yeah, we held it from modern news. And it didn't really, the news did
nothing.
Between eight and nine AM. And yeah, I don't know here.
Okay, we're almost done for April. Short continuations,
pre-obvious. It's now Tuesday, the day of April.
It shall be Tuesday, the 30th of the April.
Okay. At the end of London session, we have aggressive news, like crazy.
And I'm not even going to bother with London session. We have,
this is your own news. So maybe it's not as impactful, obviously, but it's
still crazy.
Like we have inflation rate year, year flash, inflation rate, year of year
preliminary,
GDP growth rate, quarter and quarter flash, GDP growth rate year on year flash,
GDP growth rate, quarter and quarter advanced, GDP growth rate year on year
advanced,
GDP growth rate year on year flash, GDP growth rate quarter and quarter flash,
inflation rate year on year preliminary, like there's a ridiculous amount of
news.
And so it's just, it's genuinely life and worth it. I'm interested in what
actually happens,
because most of them are like around four.
A whole bunch of, not so much, to be honest with you.
But we're looking for short tenure that wouldn't have been a setup.
Okay.
New York.
Okay. We've taken all these highs. It's a nice sweep. I still bearish.
Is that what I think it is?
It is. Okay. We should be able to short from here.
And maybe this is, this is the type of environment that you'll get a new York
reversal from as well.
Aggressive delivery like this in a, this is primed for a New York reversal.
The new, the change of character comes here.
So it's a, it's a kind of law, but New York reversal.
So we sweep a, we sweep London in the law.
We also sweep another external range of liquidity,
which is additional compliments.
And then we get the reversal, but the reversal comes inside a New York session.
So the question becomes, is where do you take the trade from?
Now let's just make sure 715, I don't think we actually do have anything, um,
four.
No, we don't actually have anything for, um,
New York session, uh, treatment.
We don't actually have anything for
US news. Sorry.
I don't know what I'm doing. Um, how can we look at getting involved in this
move?
Again, the reality is, is this entire move is engineered.
Right. We look at H one.
This is an approach move.
It's an entire move is engineered.
715, it's at 15 AM here.
What's the stop side?
Cause I know we have a large.
I know we have a large target.
If price hits all the way down here.
Six are.
We can take this.
We may even be able to scale into positions as well.
Let's see how this price like goes first before we get ahead of ourselves.
Uh, wait a minute.
Okay, just make sure we didn't risk 0.5% on anything.
Um.
Okay, let's see.
Let's see how this plays out.
Okay.
Because
maybe we'll look at trying to scale in here.
Okay, it's difficult to understand exactly where
price expects to trade away from.
We have a continuation.
A little bit more on the aggressive side.
But essentially what we're doing here is
kind of splitting our risk, although it's not technically splitting.
The risk is we find a double down on risk.
I also see this is a high quality setup as well as fine doing this.
But
I'm going to place this order as well.
Because essentially what we have here is
I believe that price could trade up here,
but I also believe that price might trade away straight from here.
Cause there's no, there's no specific area of price.
Does this fit where you go?
But there's also a possibility that price trades up into here as well.
I want to get into the position.
As opposed to just watching price sell off,
because I like this position.
Let's see.
We have a buffer where it gets up.
That's my first position over.
Okay, now I have my stops here.
Wait.
It's not, can't be ADP, can it?
Nothing contrary to your game.
But it is 8.30am, 8.30am is the type,
but I know trade of you also doesn't show ADP.
Two days, so it's very poor, 8.30am.
They're strange.
It could be ADP.
I don't see anything, trade of you isn't.
1.30am?
No, it's less.
It's not UTC.
No.
It doesn't make sense.
Okay.
Deployment cost index, ECI.
Release to 8.30am, but it's not on trade of you.
And this isn't something that happens.
This isn't something that gets released monthly.
I don't see this.
Okay.
Okay, so this, honestly, this would go down as red folder,
because that could have easily went in the opposite direction.
Oh, yes, sure.
All context, power of law.
But I don't know why trade of you doesn't show this.
It's gonna say there's no way the, there's no way the,
let me try and I'm wasting time with these guys.
Let's see.
So it's a news event that occurs once a core,
which isn't on trade of you.
I don't usually use trade of you as my entire source of
red folders, but yeah, I wouldn't take this in real time, obviously.
This one, you can say that I breach my rules.
So it's a, yeah, because this isn't moderate news.
This is as effective as a, a CPR, an NFP or something like that.
So I'm going to pull this back and we're not going to execute on that.
Again, I don't want to distort the data.
I really like this app, but I think it's
fortunate.
Well, at this point, the event has already occurred.
The problem is, is I'm going to get tagged in.
If I trade this,
and I cover New York session open,
doesn't give me the rest of the award.
If I cover the high or the price move,
I do get the rest of the award.
Let's try this.
Because the news events has passed.
The setup is still, like it's still a setup.
It's a little bit aggressive in some sense.
Both side out mind playing with a little bit of aggression
when you've had amongst those black April.
Let's see how it plays out.
So it gives a one to five.
15 minutes to get tagged in.
No, it's a black thought because it's not a tag.
Well, again, like I said,
different environments, different testing, maybe.
Curious, how does that play out?
Damn.
Oh, what can you do?
Not much.
Kind of just is what it is.
But I really like that setup.
And I'm really annoyed.
That we didn't get tagged into it.
But what can you do?
We technically haven't hit the target yet, so.
Eh, no we do.
Oh, well, that's the last day of April as well.
That would have been really nice.
London session, that takes us to the first of May.
So let's take a little bit of a look at the data for April.
And again, like one great month can bring you back.
Now we're up to 39% average win rate.
First two months, really choppy.
We might start finding some of inefficiencies
that would have made it cleaner, but again,
the more trades that you take, the better that your data will start to become.
Now we can see that we're starting to, we're starting to get there, right?
Now we're an 87 Zella score.
It's a really good Zella score.
A 3.52 profit factor, very profitable system.
I have a 39% win rate, which is more like what we want to see.
33% return over February, March.
Was that April that we just did?
April? Yeah, so averaging 10 set them up because of that one great month.
Well, actually no, last month was still recent.
That's the importance of persistence, consistency.
And yeah, pretty much just show it up every day
because you might get a month like February.
You know, it's really important that you keep showing up.
So a quick little view of our data reports and then we'll get into the next
session.
Let's have a look now at our different setups and see if there's anything still
to like in.
So discretion.
So the one position that we took based off of discretion is keeping us back.
The London sweep of Frankfurt, that's keeping us back.
But how many trades have we taken?
I've taken three trades.
We've had two losses and a break even.
So that's something that we may be looking at considering.
And again, when we come to the end, I'm going to kind of reflect on everything
and go detailed into my data and you'll see that as well.
All right, let's go back in here, setups.
All right, let's go to setups.
So what we can see here is first and foremost, really nice New York,
but a lot more trades for London sweep station, which is we already knew that.
How about how about execution window?
So every execution window of them four to five am at the moment is profitable.
News.
So no news held through moderate news,
entered after news and closed before high impact news.
All of those rules right now are showing that they are valuable.
Premium discount at the moment showing that it just doesn't really matter.
Yeah, we're not profitable on both of them.
In fact, arguably being in a premium and discount makes so far the data worse.
Right.
These are these are your questions.
I see questions of time.
Should I be sure I trade from premium discount?
Let the data decide.
Again, obviously it's still too insignificant of data, but we'll get there.
So all at the moment, all structure flows are profitable.
Trend. So when prices in a multitude of delivery,
you can see that it's unprofitable, but right now it's still only three trades.
Session.
You can see New York session is by far the most profitable with less trades.
Interesting.
Points of interest.
All points of interest have been profitable at the moment.
You can see empty legs though.
It's really interesting.
So that's basically aggressive price delivery and planning continuations.
So, we've already looked at the wins versus losses.
Let's have a little look.
Don't need to look at that right now.
What is good as well is if we do look at our losses,
we do have 14 losing trades.
However, our average losing trade is less than 1%.
Now, it's also important to understand that we're doing cumulative risk.
So I'm risking 1% of the current balance.
So right now, our account is at 1.3 million dollars.
And so I'm actually, I'm not risking 1% of a million.
I'm risking 1% of 1.3 million.
So, for example, that 1% risk is $13,000.
So it's cumulative.
So that's, again, how you may end up scaling your own accounts, whatever.
But 1% risk as of right now is equivalent to $13,000.
And our average loss is, what was it, like $9900?
So that comes from being able to manage risk and cut losses properly.
And you can see there's no trade that we've cut risk on
that has ended up coming back to kind of buy us as well.
Um, I'm not really interested in these as of right now.
It doesn't really bother me.
So we're going to be pretty much the same.
Symbols, obviously, doesn't bother me.
Options, just doesn't bother me.
Day and time.
So we see so far, best performing day is a Monday.
Least performing day is a Thursday.
Most active day is also a Monday.
Best win rate is a Monday.
So I have a 55% win rate at the moment, on a Monday.
Um, we don't really have that at the moment.
So you can see every day is profitable.
Wednesday given us Wednesday and Tuesday kind of dragging our win rate down.
Thursday being actually net negative at the moment.
But really, I think that's just a break even if I'm not mistaken.
How many trades?
Two trades.
No, no.
But yeah, like I said, we'll dive deeper into the day.
Um, we'll dive deeper into our day.
Average realized are multiple, 2.25.
Why do I feel like that's just inaccurate?
We'll come back and look at this day in depth anyway.
But yeah, that is kind of where we're at.
So, I'll catch you guys in the next one.